ah Germany is the place where BMW
Ramstein and fkk that's nudist culture
were born nevertheless Germany has
something even more important than all
of these things and that is the fact
that it is the world's ultimate Factory
yep you heard that right
and I can guess what you probably
thinking right now wait a minute Simon
isn't another country where TV screens
mobile phones and well practically every
good Under the Sun is made
[Music]
well the thing is that's not entirely
true now of course China does lead the
charge when it comes to exports but do
you know what in order to manufacture
all of those products they need to
import a lot of things from abroad
Germany instead sells way more than what
it buys in fact one out of every ten
products sold on the international
market is made in this country which has
a population 15 times that smaller than
China yes we all know those big German
car companies like BMW Audi or
Volkswagen but there is way more than
that if you don't believe me well just
consider your mobile phone and I know I
know on the back is gonna say something
like assembled in the People's Republic
of China but I'm not talking about this
I'm talking about if you open up that
phone you're going to find a bunch of
microchips inside as an example here
that chip that makes your phone tilt you
know when you rotate it and the screen
matches up that's probably most likely
made by a German company called Bosch
sensitive but not only that many of the
robots used inside these Chinese
factories assembling these phones are
probably made in Germany
[Music]
in other words in Germany they
manufacture the things they go inside of
other things that are manufactured by
things that are made in Germany and now
you might be wondering how is any of
that possible I mean factories they
should be built in places with cheap
labor costs right I mean how is it
possible that Germany with relatively
high salaries is such an industrial
powerhouse well the good news is that
today we're going to answer that
question for you but as always before we
get into all of that let's take a look
back at the history after World War 2
Europe was pretty dumb destroyed
countries like Italy France Western
Germany which was the capitalist side of
Germany they got a massive money grants
from their good friend Uncle Sam but
wait just a minute because each of these
countries used that money in totally
different ways the french president for
instance was this guy that you'd see on
TV general charles they go
de Gaulle came from the military it was
no friend of private companies his
political Creed the so called des rêves
ma was about nationalizing big
businesses and leading the whole
country's economy as if it was an army
[Music]
well in western Germany they chose a
totally different path both the
Chancellor Konrad Adenauer in his
Finance Minister Ludvig Earhart spent
years thinking about their own economic
system it was a mixture between the
competition of free-market capitalism
and the safety nets provided by the
government they then decided to give
this system what is probably the worst
name in the world ever beiie called it
auto liberalism or social market economy
[Music]
competition is the most promising means
to achieve and secure prosperity ludwig
erhard in other words while de Gaulle
centralized the economy in Paris Konrad
Adenauer designed a system where the
government would put into place a set of
conditions but the players would make
their own decisions
this explains why in Germany trade
unions regional governments and of
course companies are quite so importance
and so now you might be wondering what
are the keys that are needed for a
system like this to work and well has it
really worked out at all well let's get
right into that a stable currency I'm
pretty sure at some point you've had
some economists saying that devaluing
your currency boost exports right for
instance imagine we have a shoe
manufacturing facility in Mexico and we
want to sell a pair of shoes to the
American market let's say the price of
these shoes is 2,000 New Mexican pesos
at the time of making this video those
2,000 pesos is equal to about 110 US
dollars
let's say that all the sudden Mexican
Central Bank decides to print money and
therefore it devalue its currency from
one day to the next the pair of shoes
could be worth 90 US dollars therefore
it would be easier to sell these shoes
abroad now this is a theory that's
actually supported by most governments
today now the Germans they actually
decided to do the exact opposite and for
the later part of the 20th century the
German mark was actually one of the most
stable currencies in the entire world
and this might lead you to wonder well
how is it possible that Germany could
export so much when their products were
not actually that cheap all right well
let's go back to our shoes example for
just a moment but actually this time I'm
going to tell you the story of a real
company this is a company from the north
of Germany and it's called ESMA it's not
a particularly big business it has
around 200 staff now this company
started right after the war being
founded in 1946 and they specialized in
making machines for shoe manufacturing
now in order to do this they needed to
import lots of machines from the United
States and thanks to having a stable
currency the price for importing those
machines it was relatively low they then
decided to rent a facility because at
the end of the day since there was no
inflation rents would not go up and they
could calculate the future cost of this
space reliably
but it wasn't only that since German
companies couldn't offer lower prices
Desna had to innovate and in 1960 they
invested in state-of-the-art
technologies to manufacture rubber sole
shoes ten years later decima was the
world leader in PVC soles it's in fact
likely that these soles of the shoes
you're wearing right now are made by a
decimal machine this company with 200
staff now sells to every country in the
world including China
[Music]
and you know this is just one example of
the thousands of small and medium-sized
companies the so-called middle stand
vertebra dark Germany the middle stands
success has attracted admiring glances
from the rest of Europe but it's built
on foundations that may be hard to copy
and yes I know I know the German mark is
a thing of the past because in 2008 the
Germans they abandoned this currency and
they adopted the euro but think about it
while other countries like Spain they
were using weaker countries before
Germany had had a strong currency for
decades that means that in 2002 German
companies were already more competitive
than anyone elses but again hold on a
minute because there's many other things
that can explain the success of the
German model so let's dig into these now
the educational system now I can
probably guess what you're gonna say
come on Simon Germany isn't really
famous for its educational system is it
and to some extent that's right if you
look at the piece of report Germany
isn't even ranking inside the top ten
but then again German students managed
to find a job right after they finished
their studies so we've not such a great
educational system world why is this
happening well the answers of that
actually lies in their vocational
training system now let's imagine you're
a high school students in Germany and
you don't want to go to university so
instead you decide to study to become a
plumber well from the first moments
you're already going to be working for a
company which has an arrangement with
the school this means from monday to
wednesday you go to a classroom and from
thursday to friday you go to the
company's workshop
[Music]
there you would be trained by the
experienced plumbers and you would get a
salary of between 300 to $500 a month
and this salary is actually pretty
important because it means that the
company that are paying you really want
to make you work I mean otherwise the
firm's pretty much just throwing money
away
[Music]
and the outcome of this is that German
students know how it is to be in a real
life working environment in fact many of
them actually remain in the company
where they did their training and of
course those German firms in exchange
they get well trained workers and now
they're on the subject of workers let's
move on to another key piece of the
German system
German trade unions in other countries
like France or Spain most of the labor
laws are made by Parliament's but that's
not the case in Germany until 2015
Germans didn't even have a minimum wage
salaries were negotiated by trade unions
and employers in Germany syndicates are
extremely important actually those big
companies like Audi or BMW with more
than 2000 workers are required to have
union representatives on their
Administrative Board
[Music]
consider this Siemens has 10 shareholder
representatives on their board and
therefore they must have 10 people
representing the workers remember this
one because it makes a big difference in
Spain there's an example of another
country a big company like telefónica
has no trade union representatives on
their board of administration trade
unions can only participate in another
body which is called the Company Council
and they can only speak about matters
that affect salaries or working
conditions now but contrast in Germany
trade unions have a voice on every
decision that the company makes when
Siemens wants to start operating in a
new market or launch a new product they
have to ask the shareholders of course
but they also have to ask their trade
union representatives
now you might be wondering isn't this
just bad news for the company I mean we
pretty much take it for granted that
unions and companies not exactly best
friends well it doesn't actually have to
be their way think about it for a moment
thanks to this setup Siemens and BMWs
workers they know whether a company is
doing well or whether they're losing
money and of course when things are
going bad for the company they can make
compromises like reducing their working
hours instead of being fired to cut
working hours at German facilities this
explains why during the financial crisis
of 2008 German companies didn't fire a
large number of people
hence well this is good for the workers
and it's good for the company but wait a
minute because I know what you're
thinking right now those German trade
unions are collaborating with big
capitalists in order to exploit the
workers rights rise I mean it must be
happening well the answer there's
actually certainly not the reality is
that the average wage in Germany is
around 34 hundred US dollars a month
that's higher than the state of New York
and that's in a country with a pretty
affordable cost of living a flat in
Berlin is about half the price of a flat
in New York City and despite all of this
Germany maintains its position as the
third biggest country when it comes to
exports
so now the question becomes do you think
your country could benefit from the
German model or perhaps you think these
policies are impossible to implement
elsewhere please leave us your answers
in the comment section below
meanwhile if you do want to know about
another YouTube channel that covers
geopolitics you can check out the
Caspian report it's a great Channel
we'll put a link in the description
below and of course do not forget to
visit our friends at the reconsider
Media podcast they provided the vocals
on this video that are not mine and
remember that we publish brand new
videos every Monday and every Thursday
so subscribe to this channel and you'll
never miss any post finally if you like
this video give it a thumbs up and as
always I'll see you in the next one and
if you want to learn more about politics
and hear even more of my lovely voice
you can join us at reconsider media we
have a podcast at reconsider mediacom
slash podcast see you there
[Music]